hi everyone my name is parikshit gopalan
i'm from vmware research and i'm going
to be talking about omni predictors this
is joint work with adam kalai omar
reingold watson sharon and odi leader
so today's talk
it's about the loss minimization
paradigm in machine learning
as we know machine learning models are
ubiquitous in every aspect of our daily
lives
and the dominant paradigm for training
these machine learning models is loss
minimization
you choose a loss function else that you
think is suitable to your task and a
class of model c
and then you find the particular model
in this class
which minimizes your expected loss under
some target distribution
now this paradigm has proved to be
extremely successful
at the same time we've come to realize
that it does have certain limitations
right when it comes to digital data like
privacy and fairness
and in today's talk we're going to
explore
one aspect
one such aspect of this
which is
what do you know what do you do if the
loss function is not known to you in
advance
right
so of course firstly why is this
question interesting why is it something
we should care about
and really our definition of
learning itself is so tied into the loss
minimization paradigm
that it's a priori not even clear that
the learning task is well defined
without a target loss
for instance if your points are just
points in rn and you're trying to find a
single point that minimizes the l1
distance versus the l2 distance
we know that the answers could be very
different you get the mean versus the
median
so now if you're trying to do learning
without a loss function what is it
you're trying to learn is it even very
defined
okay so in order to address these
questions i'm going to start by
formalizing what i mean by the notion of
loss minimization this is something
which i'm sure everyone is familiar with
but i'll just go through it in any case
to make sure they're on the same page
we're thinking about binary
classification so our samples are
modeled as a joint distribution on
points and binary labels
so
once you have this joint distribution
you can define what is known as the
bayes optimal predictor
which is a function which tells you for
every point x
what is the conditional probability that
the label is one
in some sense this is the ground truth
predictor
but predictor in general is just some
function which assigns probabilities of
labels being one to every point these
might be right these might be wrong
right and the goal of learning a
predictor
is to find effects which is a good
estimate or a good approximation to the
base optimum
under some suitable notion of goodness
now in some sense if you could learn the
base optimal
then you couldn't ask for more
but
most of the time learning the base
optimal is hard for both computational
and information theoretic reasons
so we look for efficiently computable
hypotheses
so we'll allow ourselves a class c of
efficient hypotheses
and we'll allow these to take on real
values not just values in the range 1
we want this class to be efficiently
learnable so you could think of c being
like decision trees or linear
combinations of decision trees or even
say deep neural nets of a certain depth
so you have a class c and then you have
a loss function l
the loss function takes two things it
takes the description you're given a
point x
and then you make a prediction t
this is one of the arguments the loss
function the other argument is the true
label
so the game is that you're given a point
x you make a prediction
then you see the label y and you suffer
a loss which is a function both of the
label and your prediction
since we are in the binary case you
could think of two different loss
functions one associated with the label
zero the other associated with the label
one
typical loss functions will be convex in
the second argument d which is a
prediction
and when you do loss minimization
our goal is to find the hypothesis c
from this class
which minimizes the expected loss l
applied to the pair y comma cx under the
distribution d
so loss minimization as i've defined it
it doesn't include everything but it
includes a lot of very common prediction
regression boosting style algorithms
things like error boost logistic
regression linear regression and so on
are covered by this paradigm you just
use different kinds of loss functions
there
okay
now let's go back to the question we
asked
how do we
how do we decide what loss to minimize
and what if either we don't know the
correct loss function in advance
or perhaps we might be interested in
this
we might want to do learning for
a large class of loss functions like say
all lp loss functions
do we need to optimize for each of them
separately
and the point is that what could happen
is that you have the data right now you
do your learning
and what the right loss function is
going to be will only be known to you in
the future you may not know the loss
function at the time when you're trying
to learn
let's consider an example
let's say if you're trying you're a
public health officer who's trying to
decide whether people with a certain
risk profile should be allowed to do
various activities like attend a concert
board an airplane or work at an elder
care facility
now obviously this example is chosen
because you know as
you want to be if you if you're talking
about working at an elder care facility
you want to be extremely conservative
you don't want people who are with risk
of being infected with some disease to
be working there
versus maybe for attending an open air
concert you're not so you know the risk
is much lower even if there are some few
false
you allow someone who actually might be
positive for a condition to
perform this activity
right
now if you knew the base optimal of
predictor f star
then you could model this just as binary
classification with different false
negative costs you'd say that the cost
of letting someone who's actually
positive
work at an elder care facility is
extremely high
so to let someone do this i want to be
extremely confident that the probability
that they're infected is small so if
someone has a more than 0.1 chance of
being infected then i will not let them
on the other hand for these other tasks
maybe we're a bit more permissive
so here what you do if you knew f-star
is just to apply different thresholds
and require that the risk be smaller and
smaller for these activities
on the other hand
if you're doing loss minimization
you might find there's a different
optimal c for each loss function
it may not be the case that just by
optimizing for one loss function from
that you can derive the right optimal
for a different loss these could be very
different functions
in general if you want probable
guarantees you need to retrain each time
now maybe you're not exactly retraining
from scan from scratch but still you
know there's no way to just take the
predictor you have for one loss function
and somehow do some magical
transformation to it and um you know get
an optimal predictor for a different
loss function
there are plenty of heuristics of this
flavor where you train for a certain
loss then you pretend that this is the
base optimal and then you you know you
modify it in some way
there are no probable guarantees for
these kinds of methods that cannot be
this example which um you know i'm not
going to describe it in detail but
basically it gives an example
where for small changes to the loss
function
the optimal hypothesis c just in a
simple two-dimensional case is
fundamentally different so you cannot
hope to just solve it for one loss and
then post-process that somehow to solve
for other losses
and naturally as a result of this
popular libraries they come with dozens
of loss functions this is like another
hyper parameter almost you know you can
decide that i want to do this loss that
loss and so on
so what can we do about this is there a
way to get
we have said that if we knew the bayes
optimal then we would be in great
condition we could optimize for any loss
but that is computationally intractable
so what can we do if we don't know the
loss function in advance right
so this feels like a question which is
crying out for a good definition
and we propose a definition here it's
the definition of an omnipredictor
which we think of as one predictor to
rule them all
so the setup here is that you have a
family l of loss functions that you care
about
and a class c which is your hypothesis
class
our definition in this work the new
definition is an lc omni predictor
it is a predictor f
such that for every loss l in this class
there exists a post-processing function
t
from predictions which are probabilities
in the interval 0 1 to the reals
such that for any hypothesis in this
class
you can get better loss by applying this
post-processing function
to the predictor f so the loss you
suffer the expected loss you suffer
on y and the prediction p applied to f x
is less than the loss you suffer when
you make predictions according to c of x
for any c in this class in particular
you could take
that particular c
which minimizes your loss
for this particular function n
over this whole class
and we will do better than that this is
what omni prediction asks for
so the key point here is that the
predictor is something you learn when
you have access to the data
and after that for all practical
purposes you can throw the data away
when the loss function is revealed to
you you just have to compute this
post-processing function t
which it depends on the loss
but it doesn't depend on the data
right so you can just compute this
post-processing function apply it to
your predictions and you're guaranteed
that this does as well as the best
hypothesis from the class c
so this is a really strong definition
it's asking that at once this predictor
is essentially allowing you to optimize
for any loss function in this class
compared to any hypothesis from c
and the first question we should ask is
is this at all even feasible
if it is feasible
just because the base optimal predictor
it's an omni predictor
for any class l of loss functions
and any hypothesis class c
the reason is the whole the whole reason
why prediction is hard
is because you're supposed to come up
with your
action t
without knowing what the true label is
if someone told you what the true label
were
then you know it's a very then it's just
minimizing a certain convex function
that is relatively easy to do
knowing the base optimal predictor it's
almost as good as knowing what the label
is because it doesn't perhaps tell you
that the label is 0 or 1 but it tells
you that the probability
0.4 the label is going to be 0 with
probability 0.6 is going to be 1.
so again minimizing the expected loss
now is just a convex minimization
problem which can be solved
if the loss is represented nicely it can
be solved efficiently right
so
this there is a post processing function
which you can apply to the base optimal
predictor
this is not just optimal in expectation
it's the optimal prediction to make
point wise for this loss function
under this distribution
typically computing this post-processing
is easy if the loss is for instance the
l2 loss the post-processing is identity
just say your prediction if the l1 loss
you just round if the probability is
greater than 0.5 you say 1 otherwise you
say 0. so computing t star is easy
the hard part here is obviously we don't
know how to compute the base optim
so this notion of omni predictors that
they we defined it it's certainly
feasible right
the question is what is the
computational cost of
can we compute omni predictors
efficiently
for rich classes of loss functions
and hypothesis classes
so we're going to answer this question
but that requires
a somewhat unexpected detour
into multi-group fairness
specifically this notion of
multi-calibration
which was introduced in this work of
hebert johnson kim reingold and
beautiful paper from 2018.
the first thing to know is that this is
a notion of multi-group fairness
it does not say anything about loss
minimization
it starts from this classical notion of
calibration in forecasting introduced by
david
where the idea is that a predictor f is
calibrated
if the expected label of y
conditioned on the event that my
prediction is some value b in 0 1
is in fact equal to b
so a weather forecaster who says there
is predicts the percentage of rain
is calibrated
if when they say there's a forty percent
chance of rain it actually rains on
forty percent of those things and this
guarantee holds for every value of forty
percent
so multi calibration
again now there is a family c but we
want to now think of this family c as a
family of subsets of the domain at least
initially
and we say that f is multi-calibrated
for c
if it is calibrated conditioned on every
subset in this family
so this is this nice definition
introduced by this work of hkr which has
you know it's seen a lot of follow-up
and you know theory is developing very
rapidly
um one thing which they show which is
very relevant for us is that a
multi-calibrated predictor can be
computed efficiently
given a weak agnostic learner for c
so c we thought of as a set of
subsets as a collection of subsets and
think of it as a collection of boolean
functions on the domain and you want
this class of functions to be weakly
agnostically learnable
i'm not going to formally define what
that is it just means that if there is a
good hypothesis from c
you're able to find a reasonable one
that does better than random you know it
doesn't have to be perfect it doesn't
have to be the best but it does
something better than random casey
okay in this definition
when we define loss minimization we
thought of c as real valued functions on
the domain
in their original motivation
c
was meant to capture sub populations for
which we wish to give certain fairness
guarantees so naturally
in their definition the c we think of as
boolean functions or subsets right
and in this work we will give a
generalization of multi-calibration
which matches with their definition in
the boolean case but it extends nicely
also to the real bandwidth case
okay
so now i've told you what
multi-calibration is
let's get back to omni predictors
the main theorem in this work
is the following
if f is multi calibrated for the
hypothesis class c
then it is an lc omnipredictor
where l includes all convex is the
family of all convex lipschitz loss
functions
and this includes you know this is a
very wide family of losses includes most
loss functions which we use commonly in
machine learning
so basically what this says is that you
run this algorithm of hkr
which says nothing about any loss
function
you compute a multi-calibrated predictor
you can post process its predictions now
using a simple univariate
post-processing rule
such for any loss function which is
convex and ellipses you can post-process
it using the appropriate post-processing
rule and do as well as the best
hypothesis in c tailored to that
particular loss function
the post-processing rule is simple it's
the same as you would use if you had the
base optimum credit
so in some sense this goes back to the
heuristic of saying that you learn a
predictor and pretend it's a base
optimum
if your predictor is multi-calibrated
then actually you can have a very strong
guarantee for it for every convex and
lipschitz loss function
now also this connection between
multi-calibration and omni prediction
that i'm presenting it's near tight
you need the loss function to be convex
otherwise
uh this this particular multical
multi-calibrated predictors they may not
be do not have the omni prediction
property
for losses which are non-convinced
you can relax liciousness instead of
asking the function as lip should start
to then just ask that it slip shifts on
some small interval
and this generalization is good enough
to cover the lp loss logistic loss
exponential loss practically every loss
function that we are aware of in the
literature
okay
okay so
in a picture as i said um
there's a loss this family of convex
loss minimization it includes a bunch of
commonly used algorithms like aws
logistic regression and linear
regression
what our main theorem says is that once
you have a multi-calibrated predictor
for the class c
if you want to compete with or if you
want to compete with ada boost
just
use the right post processing for the
exponential loss and you know that
you're doing at least as well as data
boost
if you want to compete with linear
regression do the post-processing for
the l2 squared loss you want to compete
with logistic regression do the
post-processing that's appropriate for
the logistic loss function
if somebody came to us with a loss
function that we had never seen before
as long as it's convicts and elections
we can still do our post-processing and
you know do better than anything in c
for this particular loss function
okay
so
this theorem
you know we think of it as some kind of
good karma right like multi-calibration
wasn't defined with loss minimization in
mind it is really a multi-group fairness
notion
and from this we are able to get what i
think is a surprisingly strong loss
minimization guarantee right so
if you try to ensure the strong
fairness guarantee holds then you
actually do very well with regard to
loss minimization
but there are many other good things
also which flow from this
one thing which i think is particularly
nice is a new definition of what
multi-calibration is which extends very
naturally to all kinds of functions
including real valued functions and so
on
we think of multi-calibration as a
partition of the points the as this of
the space x where the points come from
it's a partition into points where
intuitively we think the bayes optimal
predictor
behaves similarly these are points which
we think the predictor treats in a
similar fashion
but formally here is the guarantee
within each partition
we have the condition that the
expectation of c x times y where y is
the label
is equal to the expectation of cx times
the expectation of y
this condition holds for every c in the
class
and clearly this condition you know it
makes perfect sense whether c is boolean
real value it applies to every kind of
function
now this condition intuitively says that
c x and y they behave as though they are
independent there is no correlation
within conditioned on being in this
partition there is no correlation
between the labels y
and any hypothesis from the class c
we haven't talked about predictors yet
how do you get a predictor from this
partition
well the predictor kind of suggests
itself within each set of the partition
the predictor just predicts the expected
value of the label conditioned on that
partition right so for instance if the
expected label value here is point two
we predict point two here we predict
point four here we predict point six and
so on right so this is all that multi
calibrations it is a partition of uh the
space into these regions but within each
region
the label y behaves like it's
independent of every hypothesis in the
class c
now mind you that this is just intuition
right because
if c were boolean then of course this
condition
does say they are independent when c is
real value this is not independence it's
just a first moment condition
but the intuition that we should have in
mind is that
from the point of view of a hypothesis
in c
what's going on within each partition
looks like a random process
it looks like within this first
partition every point tosses a coin
which is heads with probability point
two and that decides the label
as you move across partitions the bias
of the coin changes but within a
partition everything seems to be just
random as far as c can do
and a really neat thing is that this is
intuition but
it's made
formal and precise in a somewhat very
surprising and you know a very general
and surprising way
in this outcome
indistinguishability framework of dwarf
guitar
so this intuition we have that multi
calibration is this partition into
regions where y
looks like random to see they actually
formalize this notion in a very nice and
intuitive manner
okay so one thing that another thing
that we get here is multi calibration
this view this new definition of multi
calibration as a partition of inputs
and as we said
how do you define learning in the
absence of a loss function
well here multi-calibration suggests a
following loss free view of learning
um
[Music]
learning in the loss minimization
paradigm is a lot like studying for a
test right you try and you know you try
and learn in a way which does very well
on this particular loss function
but of course if the loss function
changes all bets are off right
multi calibration seems to suggest a
more robust and loss-free view of
learning
where we say that we are observing some
generative process
x's and labels y
the model what we are seeing as a
structured hypothesis plus pseudo random
ones so this is a structure
plus randomness decomposition of the
type which is now ubiquitous in computer
science and discrete mathematics
so here the structured hypothesis is
this partition of space into regions
and once you have this from the point of
view of c what seems to be going on in
the
in each thing is just the simple random
process
the difference between that and reality
is pseudorandom to the class c
right so this is a different view of
learning which i think it's a loss free
view of learning which i think is very
appealing
finally
this
work connects multi-calibration to the
literature or agnostic boosting so
agnostic boosting is this area you know
where there was it's it's been around
for a long time
there was this rapid progress in this
area about 15 years ago
and in fact our definition of
multi-calibration
it's a covariance-based definition which
is inspired by the works of cervidia
kalai and kalai
which
they came up with this covariance-based
view of agnostic boosting this
covariance-based definition which
inspires our definition of
multi-calibration right
and
with this connection and this definition
in place we can now go back to this
classical boosting by branching programs
algorithm of mansur and mcallister was
preceded by this nice boosting by
decision trees work of currency monsoon
we can look back at this algorithm and
just say that the final thing that it
gives us is just
multi-calibration
and now with our new understanding of
omni prediction
we are able to say something
new about the noise tolerance properties
of this boosting by branching programs
algorithm
so this is again a very well studied
topic we know that these boosting by
branching programs algorithm they have
some noise tolerance which is much
superior to algorithms like adaboost
but we are able to give by just
specializing this omnipredictor result
to the l1 loss function
we are able to give a much stronger
statement which improves our previous
work
it gives an alternate proof of results
of fellman and kalaikanani
they give algorithms some custom
algorithms for agnostic boosting and
what we can say is that well in fact the
monsoon mcallister algorithm already
gives you these kinds of such strong
guarantees
finally there is an interesting contrast
with the notion of
multi accuracy which was also introduced
in the same work that introduced
multi-calibration
multi accuracy is a weaker notion of
multi-group fairness
it just says that the expectation of cx
times the residue y minus fx which you
can think of as the error in our
predictions
is zero right so if c were boolean we
can think of this as saying that
conditioned on c
the expectation of y matches the
expectation of f
this is a weaker condition
and it's easy to achieve this via convex
loss minimization so this is shown in a
recent work with kim single and jump for
instance doing l2 regression or logistic
regression gives you multi accuracy
now what this paper says is that it
draws a contrast between
multi-calibration and multi-accuracy
and
given the strong guarantee that you get
out of multi-calibration
it's very unlikely that you're going to
be able to just write down a convex loss
function minimize it and achieve
multi-calibration
there are also other reasons to think
that multi-calibration cannot be
achieved
by convex loss minimization but
omni prediction gives us one more reason
to think so
if we did then just by minimizing this
one loss function we'll be able to
minimize every convex loss function and
that just sounds like too good to be
true
okay
okay so having told you why this theorem
is interesting let me just give you a
very
high level sketch of the proof
right
so let me just remind you of what the
definition of multi-calibration is it's
a partition of inputs into regions it's
a partition of the input space into
regions s1 through sm
such that within each region the
expectation of c x times y equals the
expectation of c x times the expectation
of y
this condition holds for all c c
for all c in this class
and then we come up with the predictor
which just predicts the expectation
within each
of these regions
and we want to claim that by
post-processing this appropriately
we can
do better for any loss function so for
any loss function l which is convex
energies
we can post process this simple
predictor and do better than anything in
c this is the claim that we want to show
we'll make the simplifying assumption
just for the sketch that f star the
ground truth is boolean so each point is
either one or zero
now we fix a convex loss l
a set c
and we will argue partition by partition
saying that post-processing a
multi-caliber the multi-calibrated
predictor
is going to do better than c for l
right
okay so here's what we do
we first define a function c prime
so this is so we're doing it we're just
focusing on one partition for now we
define this function c prime which only
takes on two values
on the points where
y is zero within this partition
c prime predicts the expectation of c
condition on the label being zero
on the points where y is one c prime
will predict the expectation of c
condition and y being one
so it just outputs one of two values
right on the zero set it outputs this
one value on the one set it outputs this
other value
okay
now because we have the multi
calibration okay because l is convex
this only minimizes the loss when you're
trying to minimize a convex loss
once you fix the label y there is just
one loss function in the picture
you'll suffer a lower loss by predicting
the expectation then by predicting
values which have huge variance right
so c prime is better than c at
minimizing l
on the other hand the multi-calibration
guarantee tells us that c is independent
of y right expectation of c well it
doesn't quite say that but it says that
the expectation
of c
does not change
whether you condition on y is equal to 0
or y is equal to 1 because then there
would be covariance between c x and then
equals pi
so c prime is in fact a constant it's
not predicting two values it's just
predicting one value
on the other hand we know exactly what
the best value to predict is for any
partition right it's exactly what you
get by post-processing the
multi-calibrated predictor
so the loss that this post-processing
gives you is much better than the loss
that c prime gives you so it's also much
better than the last sequence
but this is just meant to be a high
level sketch of the proof and if you
want more details then the paper is on
the archive
so let me just summarize what are the
main message of this paper is it is that
you know
it's this
good karma you get from multi
calibration
it gives you this incredibly it gives
you this very strong loss minimization
guarantee
it has these other nice properties
there's a nice new definition of
multi-calibration here based on
partitions which we believe is
interesting in its own right
it gives rise to this philosophy view
this loss free view of learning
and it connects to
work in the agnostic learning agnostic
boosting literature
and finally it highlights an interesting
contrast between these notions of
multi-accuracy and multi-calibration
now in terms of future directions
multi-calibration is this incredibly
strong solution concept
but it comes at a cost the cost is both
computational
and in terms of samples the sample
complexity of achieving multi
calibration is rather high right and
this comes about because really to
achieve multi calibration with um you
know there's an error parameter to make
that error parameter small
requires conditioning on rather small
probability events
maybe omni predictions suggest that this
is inherent to get such a strong loss
minimization guarantee
you need to have a very fine-grained
view of what's going on so maybe that's
why you need to understand even what's
happening in these tiny regions of space
be that hasn't been
we found in our experiments that this is
a bottleneck for real data sets you
often don't have enough data to you
don't to satisfy the sample complexity
necessity
needs of these algorithms
the situation only gets worse in the
multi-class setting when you're not
doing binary credit when you're not
doing binary prediction when there's d
different class labels
then everything becomes exponential in
the number of classes t because now what
you're trying to predict is a vector of
probabilities
there are some works which try to
address this there's this work on
decision calibration by xiaoweita which
appeared in
eurips this year
last year
and then there is some work in progress
on this notion of low degree calibration
uh this is a new notion and both of
these they try in different ways to
address this issue of sample complexity
and dimensionality they try to come up
with weaker notions which preserve many
of the properties of multi-calibration
that we like
another
direction for work is that these
existing algorithms we have for
achieving multi-calibration are not dnn
friendly and it would be nice to come up
with an algorithm which takes a dnn
which you know maybe produces a dln of
slightly larger depth which also has
multi-calibration guarantee for
a rich class of function c
with that i'll stop right here
thanks for listening
you